I've been told that I look very eager I
looking at a crotch I don't know I
thought that's not the kind of
my name is Kelly and I'm here to get my
tinder profile updated I've been on
tinder I've been on bumble and like I
don't know how to start conversations on
the Internet my current profile on
tinder is not great I even don't think
it's that great I think she look at my
profile bug this is pretty good at least
that's what I hope I'm ready to open
myself back up to dating I've been
single for over a year now when I put
myself out there and see what I can do
let's do this I'm Julie Spira I'm an
online dating expert and dating coach
and I'm going to whip some of these
online dating profiles into shape the
fit part that online dating this is over
40 million singles in the United States
alone that are using dating sites and
dating apps why is it so hard I'm ready
to check him out mobile dating bootcamp
here we go okay Ryan so I am looking at
your tinder profile and the first thing
I see is a group shot I know but the
fact is they don't belong in your
primary shot maybe it can be the six
photo but not a member that's a number
six we've got to get you without
sunglasses I picture except for the
sunglasses it's good to miss places that
you'd like to go because you need to
make it easy for somebody to ask you out
that says take me out to the ball game
that's also improved for the baby alpaca
boy sure if it was a unicorn mom it's
different men the last one you're a pig
it's just a friend
sweet I know but you want a boyfriend
not a pig I don't know get on my bias
okay I have to tell you something
profiles that get the swipes left or
ones that start by saying I'm sorry but
sexuality isn't all about your body
shape it's about walking into a room and
like owning it this is what's great
about your bio right up top it says
University of Pennsylvania and that
screams I'm super smart if it will turn
on to have somebody that can be in a
boardroom in a bedroom and you can do
both ask a question in a profile and you
have more people responding to you
because they see that question mark and
they're they're given an instruction
anything that can mirror your profile to
someone else
that's a greater chance of a right so
both of you have the same homework
assignment that you need two new photos
to replace the two I pulled down and you
need to redo your bio saying where
you're from originally you get something
unique and then ask a question I have a
lot of help for the two of you thank you
so much Julie suggested that we get new
photos for our chin to provide and we go
we're dry we're gonna come off and red
is the color of love there's research
that backs up that more right swipe some
people wearing red since we couldn't
find like red shirts we're gonna make it
really fun even though I'm nervous to
meet someone new I'm also excited cuz
even if it doesn't work out romantically
friendships are important I've never
like been dating before so I think
that's the most nerve-wracking things
like what do I say what do I do like
what if what if I embarrass myself Kelly
and I are going to take Julie's advice
you're about to start messaging me some
blame I do have to say specifically it
says that he comes from well I just
think that that have not just thing to
point out in a tinder profile moving
forward online to get yourself off line
and on a date is imperative ask them a
question and if you can use their first
name
suddenly you personalize the experience
and you're one step further along than a
person who just said hey I was swiping
earlier today and I matched with this
guy and we were just texting a little
bit and decided to go get drinks
tomorrow after work so it's pretty cool
so I did start swiping a little bit and
of course like I got one super like you
know with the blue star and the person
that super liked me is someone I've
dated already doing not great you might
write ten people and only one person
will write back and that's just the way
the numbers game it is like applying for
jobs except for it loves supposed to be
flicked for the rest of your life
potentially so why are we not playing
the same amount of energy into our love
life that's a good point I work a lot
more than I love so I just matched with
a guy named Matt
and you've been talking a little bit and
I think I'm gonna ask them to hang out
because it's all about putting myself
out there so we'll see what happens I
get ready get dressed and you're ready
to go out tonight and he just text me
about 10 minutes ago which is we're
about an hour away from when we're
supposed to meet and he cancelled it
looks like I look on the bright side of
things
I did match with another guy named Pola
messaged him and see he might want to go
out Kelly already found a date too so
we're gonna try to turn it into a double
date and see if tomorrow night works out
better than a night my experience on
tinder and Bumble it was really just
finding people that didn't look
dangerous and I've read a lot of
articles about things that really
haven't gone well for people that date
online I convinced Kelly to go on a
double date with me yeah we're gonna
make yeah yeah we're gonna do a little
double date so we're not gonna get
murdered right because we have each
other or murder together this far yeah
so we're on a double date actually so
max and Kelly are also here it's nice to
go with a friend just because it's more
comfortable automatically and I think
the two guys also had fun meeting each
other
there was no awkwardness if anything it
just felt like a nice like group hangout
axes like somehow making me nervous
because I just dropped like half my
sandwich so we didn't get murdered
that's always good meeting polo was
awesome he was a really nice guy he was
good-looking and I'd like to explore
that and see what that relationship goes
having a love expert go through my
profile it made me feel vulnerable but
it also was good because she's not a
friend so she doesn't know me personally
she just kind of said this is what a
stranger would see and this is what they
would think I don't know if tinder is
the best way to fall in love but it's
definitely a great way to meet new
people and to kind of like us put
yourself out there and just try it this
week taught me it's okay to be your
goofy weird self somebody was out there
to match you just be open to them I
liked online day
because meeting people and real-life
hard
[Music]